good day everybody and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and please allow
me to welcome you to this edition of our 2020
2021 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series it's my honor and privilege
to welcome our speaker today dr tor wager
diana l taylor distinguished professor
of neuroscience at dartmouth college
in hanover new hampshire completed a bachelor
of arts degree in music from 1992 to 1996
and completed his phd in psychology in 2003
from the university of michigan he has held
faculty positions at columbia university at
the university of colorado in boulder and since
2019 has been at dartmouth college up in new
england under the direction of professor wager
the cognitive and effective neuroscience lab
studies the neuropsychology and neurophysiology
of the effective processes involved in pain
emotion stress and empathy and how they are
shaped by cognitive and social influences his
lab is particularly interested in how thoughts
beliefs and expectations affect the brain and the
body and they use a range of techniques including
psychophysiology electroencephalography
pharmacology as well as neural imaging
to understand those processes relevant to the
brain and data science his lab is also dedicated
to the development of new computational models
for the analysis and synthesis of neuroimaging
data especially fmri and to work to promote
the open sharing of tools and scientific data
additionally dr wager is also no stranger
to providing online educational lectures
on neuroscientific data analytic approaches
he has many honors and he is funded through
currently through a number of nih r01s he has had
funding from the national science foundation the
army research institute templeton foundation
and several other um uh grants awarding bodies
um again numerous awards from the national science
foundation um the american psychonomic society
um amongst others and he also has two patents
that he is the holder of on a variety of research
projects um his topic today is going to be the
neural imaging of pain and affect generalizable
models for prediction and explanation and as
always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube and if you are watching
on youtube thank you so much for joining us
also our specially selected 2020-2021 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions for dr
weger via the chat feature in their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and ask them
on your behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of dr lager's lecture and with that welcome tour
we are looking very much forward to your lecture
great thank you so much for inviting me it's
really a pleasure to be here and to be able to
share some of our work with you and some ideas
i'm going to go back to the main reason to do
narrow imaging in the first place which is
that neuroimaging the promise is that it'll
play a unique role in this chain from molecules
to cells to systems to human behavior and disease
and since the start of neuroimaging researching
humans about 20 years ago i think we all thought
that this is going to take off and change
the world i think it is changing the world
but it's also taken longer than expected and
there have been a few bumps along the way
uh many of those bumps have made it into media in
in exaggerated ways uh so here in this in this uh
cover article from new scientists a few years ago
uh it says the vast majority of brain research
is now drowning in uncertainty uh and there
have been a number of critiques that have been
important uh including critiques of effect
sizes and how we estimate them critiques of
power and sample size in narrow imaging
critiques about our reproducibility and
how we make inferences about different pieces of
the brain especially here around huge threshold
and most recently this year critiques
about reliability of task fmri measures
uh and as you see at the bottom there uh since
this is from 2010 max cole coldheart but but the
the history of these kinds of critiques about
what neuroimaging can tell us about the mind
go way back to the very earliest imaging studies
as well and if you boil these critiques down
they're of the following things which i i was
just talking about you know effect size power
and false positives reliability inferences about
the mind and and influences about translation
they do extend these critiques beyond brain
imaging itself uh so here's an example of an
important critique of gene by environment
interactions in the field of genetics is
was really very early in jumping on this
idea that we have you know too many false
positives which stem from sort of human tests
and uh you know discover very broad critiques
of course that many of us know about why
most published research findings are false
and neuroimaging has even
been compared with phrenology
which as i'll show you is an uncharitable
comparison because there's no situation
under which phrenology can yield externally
valid predictions and inferences about uh the
mind or personality uh or individual differences
but with neuroimaging there is a lot of promise
that we can indeed uh construct measures of
task states of mental states and even clinical
uh phenomena that are externally valid and
reproducible and reliable but the central claim
i'll make in this paper is to suggest to you that
we've been doing it wrong we need a paradigm shift
and that paradigm shift is from constructing
maps which are local uh estimates of different
bits of brain and what which bits of the brain is
doing two integrated models which are uh a model
in general is a system where you specify what the
parts of the system are and how they interact with
one another and applied to brain imaging the model
will be uh specifying how different pieces of the
brain and different brain measures are combined
together and interact to predict an outcome that
we care about uh clinically or behaviorally or
in terms of performance and central to this idea
is that if we can construct stable models in
the brain of which brain features or measures
uh where we're integrating in which way then that
leads us to strong and falsifiable predictions
much of the kind that einstein for example
made based on his theories back in 1915 which
were tested years later by eddington so einstein
predicted that uh that uh starlight would uh the
light from the sun would lit with lens around
the moon when um during the eclipse and that
test of this the first empirical test of this was
really what put einstein and relativity on the map
so that's a goal for us and i'll also claim that
we need a biomarker development framework or a
model development framework where we iteratively
optimize brain patterns and features we construct
models and markers of outcomes that we care about
we validate those prospectively and test their
generalizability specificity and other measurement
properties we characterize their robustness their
boundary conditions what do they respond to and
not respond to under which conditions do they work
and not work and to the degree that we have valid
and validated models then we can we can test them
and we can start to use them to understand
what the structure of the mind is like
as represented at least in the brain um so central
this idea is the idea of contract validation
understanding what something measures and and
this takes a lot of work and this is one of the
reasons that we're really at very early stages
of developing these models as a counterpoint to
some of the critiques i'll point you to this
is a review that we wrote a few years ago now
uh it's it's a snapshot of translational studies
and here we had almost 500 studies and you
know more than 500 predictive maps that all use
machine learning or pattern recognition techniques
to do various things in various disorders and
you can see the breakdown across disorders here
there's more things coming out every
day this is a rapidly growing field
and on the right what you can see is in all these
different areas of mental and brain health there
are uh models that uh that that seem to in this
case uh predict you know who's got a disorder
versus controls with high accuracy and on the
y-axis as you see the accuracy there close to 100
each of these dots is a study and the size of the
circle represents the sample size and the larger
circles are large studies even up to and over a
thousand participants so we've come a long way
and these kinds of models are not perfect but
they're being combined with increasingly large
data sets through massive data sharing and data
and model sharing efforts and that's going to
be a theme of today's talk as well so this is a
courtesy of the uk biobank you go from a small
study to a big study to now the uk biobank study
is the largest uh study i believe currently being
collected with 100 000 individuals so we're
really moving towards population neuroscience
and here's a small table of a number of really
important large-scale efforts where data are
being collected and shared with communities to
analyze them and discover new things one example
is this you know recent effort by vince calhoun's
group they call it neural mark and one of the
important features of this is that it's a system
of classifiers based on independent component
analysis they fed in lots of data from several of
these large samples so they have 12 000 you know
people in this in this paper overall and they're
predicting on things like a diagnostic category
all right so very much different from phrenology
of old i'm going to turn to an example from our
lab and use that to illustrate the biomarker
development and testing process and what it can
do for us so traditional brain mapping is really
the the assessment or the conduction of a number
of separate tests so we'll look at a little bit
of the brain or voxel and say well okay which
psychological uh stimuli or or test states are
predicting activity in that box and then you do
it again for the next box and the next one and the
next one for a hundred thousand boxes or something
uh and what you get is a map a collection of
different local effects but it does little to
help you understand how it works or even
whether you can predict a new instance
of that test state a predictive model flips the
equation around and so now multiple brain voxels
or other features they could be connectivity
features or graph topological measures or or
anything else but the idea here where i'm going
to illustrate with uh with simple linear patterns
across voxels is that is that these brain measures
are allowed to combine together to jointly project
the outcome and once you have developed a
predictive model you can test it prospectively in
various ways so you beat on it test its properties
we can apply the models that i'm going to share
with you to new samples new individuals uh with
from different scanners and different populations
and you can um use those to predict continuous
outcomes we'll talk about predicting how
much pain are you feeling now or categorical
outcomes you know are you a patient or a control
are you unconscious or conscious uh are you
feeling pain or are you not feeling pain
and so forth so a simple version of how this looks
schematically and i think that there are many
algorithms for doing this i think the algorithms
are interesting but but not necessarily the key
thing and not the focus here that we'll take a
training sample we'll take a group of individuals
and here we're going to apply multiple
levels of painful stimuli from fairly painful
for that person to about as painful as they
can tolerate so there's four levels per person
and then we're going to use essentially a giant
regression model to identify a linear pattern that
gives us the best weights for combining brain
regions to predict pain experience so that's
what i'm going to call a signature map which is a
precisely specified pattern that we can validate
and the where sort of machine learning comes
into it is um how good that model is depends on
how you construct that the algorithm and how you
sample uh data so um you know two key ideas that
many of you know about are are cross validation
to to develop estimates and some techniques for
stabilizing those models so that you don't get a
bunch of garbage essentially so you have sort of
stable interpretable maps i'll come back to that
more again so one of the first models we developed
was called the neurologic pain signature because
we want a name that that we can reuse and refer to
and the journal editor suggested it and we didn't
want to offend the journal editor so that name's
not and this pain predictive pattern includes many
areas that we know and love in pain research and
beyond and the key thing here is that there is
a precisely specified pattern within each region
and we're integrating across regions and all
of those areas are really sensible in terms of
mapping onto invasive research in humans and
animals and so there's a there's backing from
neuroscience studies we can do many things
with this model then on on new data applied
to different individual subjects so we can take a
series like this where people get a threat cue and
then a painful warm stimulus and then they recall
pain so we have three different sort of phases of
the trial and we can apply the pain signature
to calculate a single response for every uh
trial or event and so we can take those trials
like this for a person we can use those to
predict how much pain they're feeling so now we're
looking at the pain related responses and you can
see this is one representative subject um the the
actual sort of sequence of temperatures that they
have here and then the predicted sequence um here
you can see uh the the model trained to predict
how much pain a person's feeling each line is a
person and each dot is an average over several
trials within that that individual person of
different intensities and we can take those and
we can restore those trials into the different
types of events and we can do then a test again
in new individuals so it's unbiased which
is more painful you know uh is it the heat
the anticipation period or the pain recall period
and we can then and what you see here is that uh
you know the the um this pain signature i just
showed you responds with increasing stimulus
intensity when it's you're actually getting
heat at the moment it does not respond at all
to anticipation or pain we call judging pain
afterwards and that's been consistent across
many studies now in our group and others so here
uh in a out of subject classification we can take
a new person and we're 100 accurate in the sample
you know at deciding which of the pain conditions
then we can apply this to new test data
where we take something from a person from
a different scanner we apply that signature
and what that means is we just take the
pattern weights as a template take a data image
coming in and we can calculate the dot product
uh and there's some other metrics as well
but that's the main one that we focused on
and that boils the map down into a single value
which in this case is the predicted the pattern
response or pattern expression and now we can
see here that um if we apply the nps to this
new study of multiple stimulus intensities uh it
responds with an increasing function just like
pain itself actually does and we can tell which is
more painful out of conditions where people get a
48 degree or 47 degree stimulus for example with
100 accuracy per person in a forced choice test
here's another application to a new subject from
a different scanner so they get 46 47 48 degree
noxious heat low medium and high and we can
each line as a subject and then we can turn
that into a classifier that's a continuous
readout we turn into classifier by saying
which is more painful the higher the low and if
we were to make a guess for each person in this
sample we would get it right about 96 of the time
and that's been a benchmark across studies for
this particular pattern um so this is really a way
forward you know what are some of the advantages
well for one thing we've reduced the analysis
flexibility i fixed the pattern and so instead
of testing a hundred thousand things i'm trying
to correct for multiple comparisons across
them if i'm trying to validate that signature
response i just do one test and that leads to
strong inference or falsifiable tests number
two it capitalizes on distributed brain
codes and that can increase effect sizes and
reliability dramatically relative to looking at
the standard paradigm of single regions
or single boxes uh and third it opens the
way for model sharing so i can share this
with you i'll come back to this at the end
and you can test it for yourself and you can share
data with us if you want to and we can test it
and that helps us to establish what its boundary
conditions are what is the thing actually tracking
uh and validate uh the construct that
it's actually measuring so here's a
little bit about reliability one of the
meta-analyses that just came out this year
is really a broad critique of past fmri as being
unreliable uh and perhaps too unreliable for
um to to serve as biomarkers that's sort of a
claim um and this uh is a response that was just
accepted in psychological science so it's coming
out soon and what you see here is the reliability
of pain ratings themselves across eight studies
aged dots of study which are excellent um
and you see the reliability of the nps pain
signature which is also in the excellent range
and here we actually have quite strong reliability
for even some individual regions responding to
pain like the anterior cingulate and insulin
which is not always the case actually but but
the distributed pattern is quite reliable
here are some other examples this is from
one on the left is from p generous lab a large
population health study uh predicting essentially
physiological measures of cardiovascular disease
risk and they have a uh a short-term test root
test reliability uh here that's also in the
excellent range and you can see there each
dot is a person and um and what's happening here
is it's the first half of the the session in the
second half so it's a short-term test re-test i'm
happy to talk more about the liability as well
on the right you see two examples of clinical
classification so uh the top one comes from
really a a landmark effort by drysdale and
colleagues in connor liston's lab that develops
biotypes for depression and in independent
samples they can classify depressed versus control
patients with high accuracy that's an external
validation and they can they can uh identify
which of those biotypes they are accurately and
on the bottom you see a task state classification
faces versus places so it's just a demonstration
that using the same data from the human the hcp
human connectome project that led out used
in their in their analysis we can actually
identify a distributed pattern that is highly
reliable at identifying what state people are in
and as i said the critiques of uh of
science recently have gone really beyond
fmri and neuroscience even themselves to all
kinds of fields and psychology has been one of the
main ones and so what you see here is sort of one
of the landmark papers in this area and they point
out that analysis flexibility is a huge problem
researchers have many many decisions to make
decisions about whether to stop plucking data
or collect more which outliers are the other
points to exclude which measures to analyze which
covariance to use which types of pre-processing
and modeling and correction uh i'm a fan for
example josh carp's paper where there's thousands
and thousands of different ways to analyze
the same data set and they give you different
answers right and of course which findings count
as support for hypothesis that i'm going to come
back to in a second so the term you know p hacking
sums up a lot of things um it sums up this idea of
you know iteratively making analysis decisions or
changing your interpretation in order to increase
the likelihood of finding something that
you want to see consciously or unconsciously
so this is a powerful course and i'm just going to
show you a recent paper that we did with uh juani
wu my former student who's now a professor at skku
in south korea and um and this really illustrates
the idea that analysis flexibility in standard
brain mapping paradigm is a killer so here you've
got this is a really real data example from social
rejection study that we did a few years ago and
what you see is you know a pattern of activity
in response to being rejected by another person
and so typically you might conclude the anterior
cingulate cortex is activated there's a hot spot
it survives correction for multiple comparisons
but if you look at the unthresholded patterns next
to it you can see there's a lot of information
there that's lost in that simple summary
now we do a replication and we do the same
contrast in a different sample and again we
get the same conclusion the anterior cingulates
activated wow this is a direct replication
but if you look at the pattern
what's the signal distribution
it doesn't look so clear that it's actually a
replication and so typically what we do is we'll
pick a coordinate from each of those and we'll
report that coordinate and say oh we replicated it
but how close did that coordinate have to be
how similar does it have to be from one study
to the next to count as a replication right those
coordinates are really arbitrary in this case here
there are no voxels above threshold in common
so if you look at the same voxels they're not
there's not a replication the peaks are four
centimeters apart you know and for reference the
amygdala is only a centimeter and a half big or
something so four centimeters is a huge distance
in the brain and if you look at the patterns
of activity those patterns are uncorrelated
so what juani and his team did was look at
135 studies that claim replication and most
of those studies don't provide enough information
to actually assess replication they just sort of
talk about the same brain regions of those that do
the average spatial distance between the original
and the replicated peaks is you know over two
centimeters so it's also very uh very high
um and so this is a real problem because it's
going to prevent us from aggregating results
and what i'm trying to convince you up here is
that this idea of picking the peak coordinate
and then you know comparing it or trying
to replicate that sort of general area
is essentially bankrupt um it's just too
imprecise uh another well-known study
that came out um which is also sort of quite
critical um was was by rotenbot venignezer and
a group of people called the narps study and what
they did is essentially generated a prediction
market and had a number of teams test specific
set of hypotheses uh about a task and which the
hypotheses what they are is not so important
here um but the main thing that you can see
is that uh these different teams analyze the same
data and they concluded different things right
the decisions they made about these hypotheses yes
or no are in many cases not very consistent um so
70 independent teams chose 70 different pipelines
and so that was sort of one of the taglines of
this paper but if we just look a little bit deeper
there's actually more interesting stuff going on
now this figure from the paper shows the
correlations between the spatial maps
and the reds are positive correlation so
that's good and the the entries are teams
and the reds and greens are hypotheses which
are sort of varying right but even though the
the the threshold that yes or no decisions
vary the actual maps are very similar for
a large proportion of the teams so the patterns
that there that the different groups are seeing
are highly correlated except for this little bit
over here where they think they conclude that some
people kind of did the analysis wrong or made
some mistakes right so there's another cluster
on okay so the patterns are actually much
more stable than this decision where you
apply a very stringent threshold and you look at
the tiny peaks that survive you go how similar
are those right so that's not very stable but
the pattern's on um okay and i'll show you more
examples too of effect size and reliability
but now i'm going to go to the threaded one
which is this idea that every brain area
has diverse populations of neurons in
it so when we measure a voxel we're measuring
something that is heterogeneous there are many
different populations and there's a very strong
literature and so you see some of the papers here
that's arguing that that those individual neurons
and by extension individual voxels are not how
information is encoded or represented in the brain
in fact what's a key for representing information
is the pattern across the neurons and across
specific ensembles of neurons within each region
so our job in imaging should be to identify
brain signals that track those ensembles
the track specific ensembles and test whether
they're tracking information about one kind of a
set of ensembles or one population code or another
one and that's what i think this model building
approach that we've been talking about is is doing
um so uh from this review which i i really like
uh ava beck and and boujee they say as any good
democracy individual neurons account for little
it's population activity that matters um so
highly relevant in u.s politics at this moment
in time today um so what are the principles well
cells with different functions are intermixed in
local areas individual neurons are often noisy
and they're not closely linked to behavior
and even when they are many studies demonstrate
that it's actually the pattern across all the
neurons not just the sort of most responsive or
most selective ones that's important and the kinds
of psychological functions like pain or sadness
or uh anger or um working memory performance um
all of these things or sustained attention
are not implemented in isolated brain regions
they're implemented in circuits and those
circuits involve specific ensembles in local
areas and they span multiple areas of the
brain so we have to characterize the circuit
and here are just some examples from the
neuroscience which is generating amazing
uh data right now amazing revolution in what we
understand about circuits um and here these are
all examples where you can tag uh genetically tag
and stimulate a particular ensemble of neurons and
when you tag that ensemble then you get different
behaviors so in this in this study for example
you know what they're tagging is an ensemble
related to encoding uh encoding a fear memory
and they can reactivate it and then reproduce
the behavior but it's a very specific ensemble
okay
all right so now i'm going to move on to thinking
more about what are the properties and benefits
of these models and i want to introduce this
section by making the following claim that i
hope you might find controversial which is that
the kinds of predictive models that i showed you
can serve goals of both prediction and inference
uh and therefore they're really a way forward
for many of the answers and neuroscience
that we want so this is a tale of two doctors
and these two doctors are going to look at the
same brain pattern but i want different things
out of it same brain model so doctor a is a
translational neuroscientist and she wants to
study the brain to develop biomarkers for human
disease and and um and you know why do we need
those she wants mechanistic targets or what's
happening in the brain as she's doing treatments
or testing treatments dr b is a basic scientist
and he says i just want to understand the brain
i just want to understand the brain
representation how it codes information
so dr a is interested in biomarkers which are
physiological objectively measured processes
that indicate some mental experience and why she's
interested in them is because the hidden causes of
diseases and mental health disorders that she's
interested in are hidden they are not directly
observable uh take pain for example we can't see
pain um we often can't trust other indicators
and in many cases we the pain doesn't exist yet
it's it's a predisposition so if you're going to
develop a prognostic biomarker right you need
to know who's going to who's going to get pain
later or a predictive biomarker who's going
to respond to a treatment that you can't see
um so these are really hidden mechanisms and the
main value of this brain imaging i think in this
case is to develop those uh systems models not
to recapitulate pain but as mechanistic targets
for diagnosis and intervention so for example
is this baby in pain well we don't know we
can't observe the pain we can only see the
behavior and of course babies can't tell us
uh this is a high-stakes question because in
fact even today babies uh get painful procedures
because it's commonly assumed that they don't feel
pain the same way that adults do and there's a
long history of that but there's excellent work in
neuroscience from mariah fitzgerald rebecca slater
and others uh simon beggs that really um suggest
that that they really do show all the neural and
behavioral characteristics of being in pain now
if you take a step back for a second you know how
would we know what are the underlying mechanisms
driving the pain well for thousands of years uh
theories like this one persistent that
there's you know four kinds of humors
yellow bile black bile blood and plam and they
mix in different ways right so this this affords a
whole sort of one whole set of treatments based on
what you think the underlying causal mechanism is
and of course in modern scientific
view we don't think that's true anymore
but what is it in the brain that's that's that's
in the body and the property that's creating
okay let's turn back to dr b now so dr b um is
interested in representations a representation
i'll define here a brain representation as a
causal obligatory physical basis for a mental
experience or information processing structure
so it's something where if you can activate it
in the brain you always get pain let's say
and if you turn it off you never get pain
so uh dr b might be interested in this
question well what's the representation of pain
and there have been uh a number of claims that
have gotten a lot of attention that when you
observe other people in pain that activates
a shared sensory representation it activates
your pain system and that helps you empathize so
dr b wants to know uh is that is that the case
other shared representations and so i will
suggest to you that there is really common
ground between prediction and explanation although
there are distinct goals if you think about them
uh there's the intersection is really important
so what is prediction without explanation well
it's a black box in a black box you don't know
when you can trust it when is it being unfair
what are what's driving its behavior so it's not
uh very useful and there's a big debate now about
interpretability in all kinds of machine
learning models and if you have explanation
without prediction it is just a story it's an
unfalsifiable explanation because it doesn't
make any strong predictions and so you don't know
if that explanation is right or if it's useful
um or if it's true so in the intersection
is explanation that's supported by testable
falsifiable predictions so both dr a and dr b
here are really trying to measure brain signals
related to an underlying construct it could be
pain or anger or stress or intelligence or memory
etc and if they're measuring contracts
there's a common set of empirical criteria
that we ought to be interested in and those
are whether the model is testable in new
individuals whether it's sensitive and specific
to the construct that you're trying to measure
so if pain is a construct you know it should
specific uh sensitive means it responds when
this pain specific means it doesn't respond when
it's not pain it ought to be robust generalizable
across different types or instances of pain it
ought to be interpretable in terms of the circuits
and other literature and converging evidence from
neuroscience and we ought to be able to actually
use it um okay and and test it across labs so
dr a might be interested in you know if you
have a generalizable model for pain the claim is
that it's going to respond across multiple types
thermo mechanical visceral and so dr a says what
is this thing really measuring right we don't know
is it tracking all kinds of pain is it tracking
only pain and dr b might say well which parts of
the brain are important what are the what's the
key brain representation is that shared across
social pain or um or observing
other people in pain as well
so let's look at generalizability for a second
um there's this idea that there are gradients
of generalization of multiple kinds so for any
brain model you know you might be interested in
what it tracks uh is it only a very specifics in
this condition one type of pain in one spot um
is it a class of similar states is it very diverse
exemplars of all kinds of examples of the concept
you might be interested in which populations
who in whom is this model only applicable to
one person in you know in one sort of moment and
that's what most of the mdpa or predictive models
from vision for example and other areas are
designed to do they're only supposed to apply
to one person but all the models i'll show you
are designed to generalize to other groups of
people maybe new individuals from the same sample
or population maybe multiple samples of different
characteristics or maybe even heterogeneous
populations um and you might be interested
in in which contexts does this model predict
the outcome that's intended to break let's say
you know a very narrow context with the
exact same cognitive and stimulus conditions
a similar context or a very very broad set
of contexts is it robust across many of them
so we can test if we have a model we can apply
to new individuals in new studies which we do
we can test this in various ways so this is
just one example of that same pain signature
being tested on a data set with uh 20 different
studies from around the world the 600 people
so they are relatively diverse populations uh
at least compared to most studies um and it's
diverse in terms of the types of pain that's
being assessed electrical heat laser mechanical
visceral which is actually a rectal balloon in
this case um so multiple types of evoked pain
and what you see here is each of the rows is one
of the studies or the 20 studies and um a shift to
the right means the study is a resp the response
the nps the pain signatures responding to pain
and the small dots are individual participants
so you can see all the individual participants
and what you can see is is that it responds
in the right direction for the vast majority
of participants 95 and the effect side is massive
uh for reference russ poldrick published a really
nice paper called scanning the horizon in 2017
and the broad claim for our purposes is that if
you look in areas where you see a real signal you
know there's a real signal and you're measuring
how big it is but it's an isolated area effect
size about 0.5 which is moderate effect size
moderate reproducibility and power
and here the effect size is much much larger
so you can really see this in individual people
let's take a look at specificity i'm going to go
back to this idea about observe pain and self pain
experience pain and it really does matter so one
of my favorite sort of boils here david brooks
like many of the things he's written he wrote
this article called the archipelago of pain
and what it claimed is that self pain physical
pain and looking and um and um looking at other
people in pain or um or experiencing social
pain are all look the same in the brain and
because they all look the same in the brain then
we really ought to uh treat emotional distress
differently when it comes to policy um and
indeed you know um you know yeah should we
treat emotional harm like physical harm then
right and and indeed there are published papers
and a lot of data suggesting that at the sort
of overall level um these things really do look
similar they all activate the interesting
unique cortex they activate the answer in solar
um so here's a pattern-based study so what are the
population codes show us well here we have somatic
pain and vicarious pain so looking at other people
in pain and we have two locations for each arm and
foot and we have three pre-selected intensities
designed to create a variation in the range of
of somatic pain and a variation in the
range of vicarious pain so how bad is it
and what we can see is these are the pain ratings
that they're matched across both there's really a
nice distribution that's similar in pain ratings
and people think both of these things are bad
somatic pain vicarious pain okay so now we can
ask what happens with our pain signature does
it respond to vicarious pain the answer is no
it doesn't it tracks pain when it's self pain
those are the warm colors across two body sites it
doesn't mean we can't discriminate body sites too
but this pattern works for both body sites to a
large degree it shows a really nice dose response
function but there's no response to looking at
somebody else in pain so at the pattern level
this is quite different and in this paper we
demonstrate this in many many ways essentially
um beyond what i'm showing you here and we can
take the same data and we can ask is there a
signature in the brain or a pattern that tracks
vicarious pain the intensity of vicarious pain
again all these are new individual
subjects so they're all sort of unbiased
tests that you're seeing here in the graphs and
the answer is yes and it generalizes across hand
and foot and maps stimulus intensity very
nicely but there's no response to self pain
so this pattern is called separate modifiability
and it's one of the strongest criteria that i know
of for process separately we've got two patterns
that respond to two things we can do this across
the brain we can do this with individualized
patterns we can do it with selected areas of
the brain they're supposed to respond in common
like the anterior cingulate cortex and we get
the same answer we can also replicate this with
different paradigms so here's another study where
women came into the scanner and their male partner
was outside the scanner so they experienced uh
pain for themselves and they were watching their
partner's arm through a mirror which was always
present so the visual stimulation is constant
but then they were cured that their partner was
going to experience pain and so there were some
periods where they knew that their partner was
getting pain even though there was no visual cues
and we can look at the neurologic pain signature
for soft pain vicarious pain signature and we
again see this separate modifiability process
so and you can see the individual subjects
here as well as the bar graph in the group
the nps responds only to self pain not
to pain on the other but the vicarious
pain signature responds only to pain
on the other not to pain on the cell
so it replicates that pattern in the new
study and the thing about specificity is
that it's an open-ended process you can always
think of something that maybe that looks like pain
but it's not pain right maybe it's breathlessness
or maybe it's something else or maybe it sounds
or maybe it's some you know you can keep
going which is great but we have to of course
test that across studies so it's an open-ended
process so we can assess specificity as well as
generalizability on new cohorts and so for this
demonstration i'm going to show you uh a data set
that um that phil cragal collected together for
multiple studies and here there's 270 participants
um and a third of them get pain and the
pain is divided up into three types of pain
thermal visceral and mechanical and there's two
studies of each type of pain and 15 subjects
and there's three studies of cognitive control
working memory response selection response
competition two studies of each 15 subjects
and there's three types of negative emotion
from pictures from social cues and from
auditory cue sounds and two studies of each type
so it's a systematically sampled set and the point
of phil's paper i'm not going to tell you about
in this talk but i encourage you to read it if
you're interested in generalizability because the
point is that you can identify generalizable
representations using this systematic set
that are not shared across across other domains
and you can test their generalizability but for
now i'm going to stick with the pain signature
i'm just going to show you the nps responses
across all of these data sets and again the dots
are individual subjects the bars are studies
so you can see that there's a threshold at
which almost all of the pain subjects respond
and in very few of the other conditions maybe
one of the auditory studies there you know
most of the studies they don't respond um you know
the nd or i should say the nps does not respond
right you can try all these things yourself by the
way so we built a whole system of tools if you're
interested in this and you can use our k lab code
tools on canva.github.io and you can you can try
this you know with two lines of code and reproduce
it so overall we've been actively sharing uh data
and models with people across laboratories and
it's been really fun because i've sort of gone
around and given talks and said well maybe you
have something that looks like pain but it isn't
pain it's an interesting test case so let's test
it out and by sharing these data across these
different cohorts we've been able to characterize
what this thing this measure responds to and what
it doesn't respond to of course there's more
to go but this is a snapshot so far it does
respond to multiple types of above pain and to
some degree things like are somatic distress
like breathlessness um aversive taste and painful
sounds although they don't seem to track with the
intensity uh they don't track the intensity in
the same way and it doesn't respond to a number
of tests uh and some of which we've discussed you
know um aversive images arousing salient horrible
things looking at um the person who rejected
you so social rejection cues looking at
other people in pain anticipating pain and other
conditions including some somatic ones potentially
um okay so now uh there's this idea that when
you have gone through this process and validated
a model in all these ways the more you know about
the model the more useful it is and then testing
interesting test cases and making some inferences
about the mind so this is where these hard-won
instances about the mind come in at the end right
of this process and so you can ask is this baby in
pain well again we never know because we can't
observe that baby's internal state but what we
can do is apply the nps as a validated measure to
infant data after appropriately normalizing them
so eugene duff put a lot of work into trying to
match the the brains and apply the signature and
what you can see here is an invalidation adults
it responds this is uh uh the sort of um propane
no susceptible uh part of the nps it's it's
responding you know in adults um there's an
anti-pain system part which is this sort of
a default mode and visual cortex and things
are deactivated with pain um it does not activate
and so that's a validation that that the system is
working in this study for adults across stimulus
intensities and then applying it to two studies in
infants where again that propane nps is increasing
uh across stimulus intensities so infants are
encoding that and that's one piece of the puzzle
among others that suggests that that yes infants
have very similar neurological responses to
pain as well as similar kinds of behaviors
okay so um i'll drop talk a little bit
about interpretability and model sharing
before i wrap up so um interpretability is
really important and we've been thinking a
lot about how to do this and so i want to point
you to this paper that came out recently this
is from juani wu's group um carrying on a sort
of elaborate and detailed program of research
and in this paper we really thought about
different kinds of ways of interpreting and
validating models uh and so there's a feature
level assessment which is some human readable
representation of what which voxels uh or which
features contribute to that pattern so how do
you reconstruct a sensible map and there's
a model level assessment asking things like
does this track compounds or is it independent
of compound could be head movement um and many
others right um you know is it generalizable et
cetera um and biology level assessment which is
um you know which means that you have to take the
the features of the model and interpret them in
relation to past literature and animal studies
so do you get sensible pathways that match what
you'd see in animals and can validate externally
i think all those things are really important
okay so then you know we can uh develop
experiments and there's this whole progress
i'm not going to walk you through all of this
but there's a whole process that um that we
outline in this paper of developing provisional
models and then doing a lot of the hard work
to say does it does it perform well um is it
independent of compounds like head movement or
medication usage or something like that if it's
a clinical biomarker and that involves testing in
new data and then uh and starting to interpret the
model features do they make sense are they in the
brain are they in places where we can uh validate
them are they stable and reproducible features
uh and then is the model generalizable is
it biologically plausible you know so some
award-winning models in the brain have turned out
to uh to track activity in the ventricles where
there's no real signal so that their problem
or track head movement essentially in in fancy
ways right and if we fail these tests we have
to sort of go back and and re-engineer better
models um and then we can start to understand
you know how it performs on new data more broadly
and so forth so this is some simple ideas uh we
can take these resting state networks is just one
way of characterizing any of these models right
and we can break them down into the loadings on
these large scale networks so here's a signature
that tracks emotional experience and you can see
which networks it loads positively on ventral
attention and visual networks um and inside the
circle by the way there's negative correlations
with photoparietal dorsal attention somatomotor
networks but if you look at our our pain
signature that's what we've been talking about
the nps it loads positively on ventral attention
to many motor networks a very different pattern
if you look at the vicarious pain signature it
also shows a very distinct pattern of network
loadings so they're really different
large-scale systems that we're tracking
and here's some code if you're interested in
that another kind of interpretation is we can
we can ask how much of the brain and in which
systems do you need to accurately make a
prediction about pain or about emotion or whatever
your outcome is and so in this demonstration
we have a comparison between the best single
region which is way down here it doesn't work
very well at predicting pain and the whole
brain model is way up here at the top end
and what you can see is a single
region doesn't do very well
as you add voxels that's you're moving to the
right you end up getting more and more accurate um
and it levels off here at some point and and these
lines are when you run the prediction with only
the an individual network only the somatomotor
network for only the the voxels in the ventral
attention network and you can see that no model
really does um uh as well as the whole brain
and bogdan petri has a preprint from my lab
that that really goes further and characterizes
this in a lot of detail i think it's a great
paper but i'm not going to talk about it here
we can also take a model like this which is
across the brain and we can break it down
into its local information content so this
is a predictive model from another study um
that we developed based on several hundred
people and then we can go back and say well
this is a pain predictive model well what about
what about the thalamus is is the signal is are
the contributions different in different parts
of the thalamus and here you see that they are
um actually and this is a beautiful fella i
make atlas by morel and the morel atlas um
uh which which they shared with us and you
know you can see here what i put stars over is
all of the thalamic zones that really are known to
convey nociceptive and pain information from the
uh from animal studies and human invasive studies
um and so you can see the the larger the wedge
there the the greater the the pattern weight there
the greater the contribution in the model to pain
and we can break it down into thalamic regions and
other brainstem regions that are really important
in animal models but that are very seldom
discussed in human models okay um and now i'm just
going to wrap up by talking about model sharing
and going back to this idea of the snapshot of
translational neuroscience well we have a problem
here because we have 500 studies and we have 500
different models and we don't really need you
know 100 models of alzheimer's disease and 100
models of ptsd which are all different and hard
to compare we have what my old colleague will
alter michelle called the toothbrush problem
which is nobody wants to use somebody else's
and in fact in this review we characterized the
models at the time and there are a small handful
that have gone from single sample to perspective
validation in a new sample actually being tested
in a brand new sample unbiased and there's a
few models that are named here you can see this
um orchid stands there's some alzheimer's
models um spare ads alzheimer's pdrp is a
parkinson's disease related pattern by david
eidelberg's group and so you know as you march
into the more and more data and more replications
across laboratories there are very few of those
named models but that's a really important
thing and we have to share models and test them
so to that end we've started sharing all of our
models i got inspired by the idea of a model zoo
in an ai a lot of the deep neural network models
you know for example are shareable and reusable
and it's great um so we have we have a website
here and a github repository where we have
shared multiple things all of the multivariate
predictive models um including now the the nps
that i showed you and others so you can download
them and and try them out for yourself and
there's a there's a growing family of them um
meta-analysis masks from meta-analyses over the
years that you can apply to new studies uh brain
parcellations and some of these are from our lab
and many of them are from other labs
that uh that agreed to share these
data too i'd be happy to um to host
them as well because i think the more
focal points for sharing we have the better so
in sum i have talked to you about the idea that
we need a paradigm shift from isolated brain
maps to integrated models that predict outcomes
i've used pain prediction as an example of how
we can test this model across many conditions and
studies uh and and share date both data and models
um and i've talked about some of its properties
and benefits including large effect size high
reliability uh high uh reproducibility of effects
high specificity to a construct in this case
pain and high generalizability across multiple
types of evoked pain and then finally i've
talked about the idea of sharing these models
and working together which is really the fun part
of science and i'm just going to end by saying
thank you to my current lab members and my former
lab members many of whom aren't collaborating
i'm still and have contributed a tremendous amount
and to our funding agencies over the years and
thank you very much for your attention torah thank
you so much that is really an impressive body of
work to try to understand the brain's response
to pain and the role of cognition emotion um
with the goal of trying to find out what can
be generalizable what can be explainable and
how you can leverage computational models in order
to give you some insights i i want to invite our
our biomedical data science seminar series fellows
to contribute any questions they have for dr wager
via the zoom chat feature and while we're waiting
for those to accumulate um i wanted to get your
your thoughts you presented a number of different
studies some of which were kind of mega analyses
that is just very large numbers of subjects that
you actually have the data for and can reprocess
versus some of the other studies that you
looked at which were meta-analyses where
you're drawing from what people have reported in
the literature and when just in my own experience
and perhaps this is yours as well the studies
which tend to be very critical are those which
are the meta-analytic ones they always seem to
be the ones that kind of show everybody what
they're doing wrong and i'm curious about your
comments about that in the context of reliability
and whether or not the choices of processing
which are going to be very heterogeneous when
you're doing a meta-analysis of the literature are
those different from what you're doing in a very
large sample mega analysis like the uk biobank and
if you have any thoughts on the distinction there
and whether or not that's an important factor and
some of the heterogeneity that uh we're seeing
yeah you know think jack um no i think i i
spent um probably 15 years we're still doing
i'm doing doing coordinate based meta-analysis so
summaries from published papers to characterize
what's consistent in the literature i think those
things are really useful and like i said we're
still doing some but um those coordinate summaries
like a paper and a table is a really impoverished
sort of picture uh and so we've really tried to
move i got excited about you know towards this
sort of mega analysis approach where we're getting
you know the the full image data the full set of
effect sizes because you can use so much more with
it and ideally even the individual person level
maps because then you can really test you know for
for individual by individual how often would we
make a correct prediction you can look at spatial
similarity across you know brain patterns and
and and data sets um uh and you can you can
test you know the the rough workability across
um subjects and make population inference in
that way so i i like the meta-analysis we've
got i've become a real fan of the you know sort
of the integrated data sharing um mega analysis
approach and i think it can be used to make
very critical points but it can all you know
but it could also just be used to generate new
um new hypotheses and data and models are there
any dangers with problems of like publication
bias in meta-analytic assessments you know we're
really people only publishing those things which
are statistically significant so we're leaving
out a possible bunch of null results that could
inform some of our uh meta-analytic statements
yeah no right i think there's lots lots of
issues one that comes to mind that you sort
of highlighted is you know if let's say you're
you're summarizing uh published effect sizes from
papers right and every fear study does a region
of interest analysis then you make them and they
always find it because it's special very liberal
right and so what do you do you know do you
include everything that's what we've sort of done
and then you find the amigo is really important
but is it really the strongest signal in the brain
related to fear uh no it's not not even close
right and there's some new work that actually
shows that or do you leave those out and say we're
not going to publish roi analyses but then you
you've um you've excluded all the studies where
people tested principled hypotheses right and now
so it's really a hard problem the idea of bias
uh bias in sampling bias and selection going
in is a really difficult problem um if we share
data and we get the full maps that actually
really uh helps i think in that regard i have
we're at the top of the hour here but i want
to ask one more question there's a bunch of
them coming in which i'm happy to share with you
offline dr wager but uh because of time i want
to get this last one really what what is the role
you met you presented a bunch of work that really
looks like it has a lot of data science in it
there's a lot of computational modeling you
mentioned machine learning deep learning support
vector machines a number of different techniques
what role do you think that card carrying data
scientists have to play in order to help identify
robust and robot reliable patterns that might
be useful as biomarkers in things like pain
and the brain yeah i think that data science is
super important um i mean it's like a basically
essential skill set then to be able to do these
things um but what i'll also say is is that
what i think the most successful sort of sweet
spot is is somebody with those the skills the
data science skills the technical skills the
mathematical skills and computational skills
but also a real interest in the brain in
understanding how to translate the sort of
technical bits right into what are people going
to understand what does the field need to know
what do we need what you know what level can
we can we uh frame this or describe this to
really make it understandable for the audience
which is which is you know neuroscientists and
psychologists and and the public so i think there
is this sort of real intersection of interests
right that's going to characterize
very successful uh people in this area
well with that i want to thank uh dr tor wager
from dartmouth college for a fantastic uh tour
divorce uh on discussing of uh how to characterize
the brain's response to pain how to generate
models that can be uh both explanatory predictive
and useful um and for sharing them all i think
that's wonderful and uh so thank you again
dr wager i really appreciate it i want to
thank everybody who joined us and uh i want to
wish everybody a very good weekend uh take care
everyone thank you thank you i'm happy to answer
some things over email too if you um send me the
chat and i can i can respond to so many questions
fantastic we'll do that take care everybody